steht dauerhaft in einem selbst wenn er
in ihm steht kein hingeben das ist kann
eigentlich die connection sein dachte
bis heute eigentlich dass es keinen weg
gibt der ein und treffen für andere
macht aber das hier ist schon mega
komisch aus
josefsson herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute was für video ist es
noch mal herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge der hacker schon heute habe
ich gleich fünf einhand fünf hektar für
euch in diesem video und ich habe mal
einen neuen countdown ausprobiert meine
kommentare was ihr davon haltet
bevor wir loslegen mit den besten fünf
habe ich die kleine vorspeise für euch
die stammt von chrissi 15 05 schreibt da
kennt sich wohl jemand nicht mit seinen
hacks aus verdi volkes bisschen zu kurz
deswegen zeige ich ihr euch halt nicht
als richtige einsendungen vorne weg und
wir gucken mal rein
der typ bank auf jeden fall schonmal
nice hin und her und [ __ ] alter wie
schlecht das ist so der fall weil man
einfach keine ahnung unseren hexer
selbst mit hacks einfach nichts gebacken
bekommt durch das an
warum dass er ihn sieht
entweder sie um moment manche können
jemand geschlagen wo ich center jede
idee nicht gesteigert ok einsendungen
numero sowie fangen wir ganz classic an
und zwar mit jump league die einsendung
stammt von mo kang das ist ein zuschauer
auch schon öfters bei mir im schönbuch
an dass du jetzt mal den weg in die
hacker schoko von nas oder schicken
video namens herr kein jump league
wisst ihr es fühlt sich einfach schon so
an als würde ich nach hause kommen es
fühlt sich einfach an als würde ich nach
hause kommen wir einfach in jeder folge
hacker schon schön beyblade hacker da
hat hier heißt der typ
wisst ihr was ich hab was für euch ok 3
2 1
sehr tragisch zentrale chef jeden fall
ich sage immer beyblade dazu aber ich
weiß natürlich auch dass es der der der
pack ist das war es von dieser
einsendung springen zu platzen nummer
vier
der stammt von gaming tv germany oder
schreibt usain bolt auf mein plex alles
klar
eine weitere kraft alles klar wie
schnell usain bolt die 100 meter in
diesem clip gelaufen ist also der
weltrekord liegt bei 9 kommen weiß nicht
verwerten konnte
der clip anschauen ich glaube es besser
natürlich okay da hinten jeden alters
wohl diese kombination aus diesen
übertrieben speed weg und da wird er
sich die gegen brecht sowie haben sie
noch mal kurz mal den
geschwindigkeitsmessern machen
das sind 103 und 53 und sieben und acht
und vier ihren drei kammern und glück
gehabt dass die polizei nicht da wird
das sofort seinen führerschein verloren
okay das reicht auch wenn mein ellbogen
sich in die senkrechte erhoben hat
springt zur nächsten einsätze
die nächste 1 sendung stammt von jannik
nüsken oder schreibt hecke reporter für
ghd punkt net für gomez klar gut
komponiert das dann hätte report ich
schick dir nur mann dich weiter vom hd
punkt net alter ich weiß nicht was ich
davon halten soll jannik comcom chance
es kommt mir gesagt hat nach für
komponenten wahrscheinlich aufkommen
okay so wo ist jetzt unser hacker der
teamchef mit diesem typen da in den
wenigsten
das ist schon mal sein teampartner so
mindestens heck ist gut
da ist alles klar
leider kommt nicht an den rand wo er
steht in ihm drin sein schwert für die
jusos aber er kann den typen nicht
schlagen
er kommt einfach nicht an dann kommt man
hier
ich will ja normalerweise sagen das ist
ein connection problem aber der typ kann
einfach gar nicht schlagen also steht in
ihm drin und kann ihn nicht schlagen
megafon fordert da an dieser stelle gibt
eben kurz ein hit oder ab diesem
zeitpunkt erwischt einfach niemand von
ihnen mehr den hacker komme keiner von
den beiden einzigen gegeben achtung auf
das schwer das wird die ganze zeit uses
aber er kann den typen um nicht hätten
und dass das das krasseste steht in ihm
man kann ihn nicht schlagen steht
dauerhaft in keinem selbst wenn er in
ihm steht kein hit game connection sein
dachte bis heute eigentlich dass es
keinen hack gibt der einen und treffer
für andere macht aber das hier ist schon
mega komisch aus also wie man die frage
an euch gibt es ein hack mit dem man
nicht mehr von angetroffen werden kann
wenn ja wie heißt der oder war des tcw
garten connection probleme nichts kann
ich seine jja in dem typen kann wenn es
sowas gibt dass man vor anderen tag
nicht mal getroffen wenn kann deshalb
sohn in die kommentare
hut ab zur nächsten sendung die nächsten
sendung stammt von das kuchen
ich sag nur so range dankeschön lieber
das kuchen wir gucken mal rein was unser
geschickt hast ich hab ja so ne ahnung
wir hatten schon mal so eine situation
während der typ sieht irgendwie was
beute da ab okay die sehr grüne ist
nämlich ob wir achten auf den namen ich
bin eh was sein können selber surfer 29
29 hat zwei blöcke abgebaut
ja da ist er wieder da ist er wieder der
100 blöcke janecek aus der letzten folge
hacker show die habe ich übrigens hier
drüben verlinkt falls ihr nicht gesehen
hat unbedingt abchecken
da hatten wir diesen hack einfach schon
mal und ja der zeichnen sich dadurch aus
das sollte aber so darstellen
die luft sind hier bis hin da und dann
einfach so blöcke also betten abbauen
die auf der komplett anderen seite der
maps sind also
jahrhundert blöcke entfernt nur mal kurz
rein und schauen wir es macht ja dass
ich es steht da schlägt in die lüfte zu
klopf klopf klopf feuchtmann am baum
sollten vielleicht das bett von timo
lemmer leute kennt bestimmt auch diesen
moment wo er einfach so denkt zum moment
mal in diesem baum ist das bett von pink
und moment mal im gleichen baum ist auch
das bett von team grün
es gibt sie nicht vom bau die alle ihre
betten im einbaum rein ich weiß ich
gesagt nicht mehr welche heck das war
ich meine hexen auswendig gelernt leute
glaube es war krieg m2m euro was wenn
ihr spontan bis können dass wir meine
kommentare schreiben und mir auf die
sprünge helfen
dem jungen erste seine hexen nicht
gelernt hat aber bitte keine schlechte
note geben dafür also wer echten wir den
meckern schlechte noten den kommentaren
geben würde
ich wusste nur den einen hack nicht
ansonsten weiß ich meine ex möglich okay
leute das waren soweit die top vier
dieser woche und auf platz eins ist ein
von der einsendungen die musste ich
einfach rein nehmen die musste ich rein
müssen spiel das den flächen jeder von
euch spielen das ist mario party auf
seiten glaube ich aber geht das einfach
mal die idee ist einfach zu geil platz
eins kommt von wie keller tv und wir
gucken mal eine kelle uns geschickt hat
ok also es im spielmodus ski stand das
heißt man hat da da unten da unten hat
man so nicht stellen will das so ganz
dass ich beim schießen einfach so viel
kirche nach auflaufen muss sich aber mit
dem bogen abschließen und ich bin
gespannt wie man daher
ich habe schon eine idee ja ja ich
musste es einfach er fliegt da unten hin
von da einfach alle leute und beschießt
wieder einfach so ab a classic alter das
eiskalt das ergebnis sollte ohne
wirklich liebe wie dreist dieser typ
einfach ist er fliegt aber nach vorne
zwischen die monster die man abschließen
sollten schießt aber sowas nicht alter
diese idee sondern als und im nächsten
mal erneut maxi spur
ich glaube dieser moment einfach wenn
der hacker zu intensiv läuft einfach
eiskalt los ihr wisst ihr diese ganzen
bett wars sg skyward jamaika können
einfach nicht gut wie style hatte das
wasser reichen dürfte idee gekommen ist
einfach mal in fakten mario party zu
hätten
wie kommt man auf die idee so also wie
man dem brettspiel hätten
sechseinhalb stunden später leute davor
aus von heute irgendwo gehört abonniert
alle sp und cvp 6 auf youtube danke